[Musique]
merci Stéphane piénoir de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu du menelir
membre du groupe les républicains vous
êtes professeur on va parler longuement
bien sûr de ce qui s'est passé hier au
Sénat de ses auditions sur les menaces
contre les enseignants mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est la loi immigration et
la commission mixte paritaire qui se
réunira donc lundi en attendant
ellisabeth borne multiplie les
rencontres notamment avec les
républicains est-ce qu'un accord vous
paraît
possible pour moi les choses sont
relativement claires en fait il y a
qu'une seule copie vous savez qu'une
commission mixte parétaire ça consiste à
regarder les les deux copies celle de
l'Assemblée nationale celle du Sénat
tout le monde sait ce qui s'est passé au
Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale lundi et
donc cette CMP elle va se elle va se
dérouler sur la base du texte du Sénat
donc qui qui est déjà le fruit d'un
consensus d'ailleurs j'entendis Hervé
Marseille qui dit on doit encore avoir
des des
échanges ce texte du scénat est l'issue
d'un consensus d'un travail de de
plusieurs jours de plusieurs semaine au
Sénat et et donc je je je vois mal
comment on pourrait bouleverser bien sûr
qu'à la marge il peut y avoir des des
des des corrections mais bouleverser ce
texte ne paraî pas raisonnable donc oui
je je je je je pense que tout le monde
est partant pour valider ce texte il y a
des nouvelles ligne rougge qui semble
apparaître l'article sur la
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers en tension ne semble plus être
un problème le gouvernement et la
majorité présidentielle seraiit prêt à
se rallier à l'article du Sénat sur
l'aide médicale d'État d'abord est-ce
est-ce que vous vous êtes prêt à sortir
cette réforme du texte et à la remettre
à plus tard comme le souhaite Gérald
harmanin non mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il a il y a plusieurs Gérald haranin
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour pour
l'homme mais en tant que ministre il y a
le Gérald haranin qui dit à François
Noël buffet le président de la
commission des lois ici au Sénat je
valide le texte on a fait du bon boulot
je soutiendrai ce texte à l'Assemblée
nationale et puis le géralde dermanin
qui dit exactement le contraire à Sacha
alier il dit carte blanche pour
détricoter ce texte pour enlever toutes
les mesures qui avent ellement pourrait
constituer un écueil et et on arrive à
une situation de blocage donc il faut
que il faut que le ministre à un moment
donné soit raisonnable dans le sens
premier du terme et et tienneent ses ses
engagements qu'il a pris ici au Sénat
donc on va pas redétricoter un texte
encore une fois maisce que là le
compromis ça pourrait être de dire bon
cette réforme de laame on l'a fait pas
maintenant on l' fait un petit peu plus
tard mais c'est c'est une stratégie vous
savez on a bien vu le le en même temps
qui qui qui nous qui nous mène à un
crash monumental d' on peut s'étonner
d'ailleurs qu'on ait pas eu plus de
d'accident industriel avec on est on est
dans un avion depuis 2017 avec un pilote
totalement ivre qui a pas de GPS et qui
tient pas compte des des consignes des
tours de contrôle qu'il rencontre sur
son sur son vol aujourd'hui non enfin ce
ce texte il a voulu que laame la réforme
de laame de de la Muu soit dans ce texte
il faut aller jusqu'au bout et il faut
bien expliquer que ce qu'on a mis dans
le texte c'est pas du tout une absence
de soins pour les personnes qui arrivent
sur le sol français c'est juste que il y
a probablement des soins un peu
superflus en tout cas qui sont pas
essentiels dont on peut se passer et il
faut restreindre laame comme le font
tous les pays européens d'ailleurs alors
je disais il y a des nouvelles lignes
rouges qui apparaissent notamment la
suppression de l'article qui conditionne
le bénéfice de certaines prestations
sociales à 5 années de résidence sur le
territoire et puis un article sur le
durcissement de l'accès à la nationalité
ce sont les liges rouges qui ont été
posé hier soir par les députés
renaissances est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
des compromis là-dessus écoutez moi je
d'abord je serai pas dans la CMP euh et
je fais confiance à mon président de
groupe Bruno retillou pour regarder au
cas par cas mais mais est-ce que
l'objectif c'est d'aboutir à un accord
mais nous on est tout à fait y a pas
d'accord et que ce texte part à la
poubelle t bien sûr oui c'est le c'est
le risque et Emmanuel Macron en a dit de
beau hein s'il y a pas d'accord en CMP
je n'utiliserit pas un 493 et et on
retirera ce ce texte quoi qu'il arrive
mais mais mais vous savez cette on est
là pour représenter les territoires on
est aussi là pour entendre la voix des
élus qui nous disent vous savez nous
dans dans n dans nos communes y compris
dans nos communes rurales les Français
en ont assez de de de devoir cotiser les
temps son dures pour tout le monde et à
côté de ça on a des droits qui s'ouvrent
automatiquement pour des gens qui qui
arrivent sur le territoire il faut qu'il
il faut qu'il y ait un équilibre sinon
on va arriver pas une situation de
blocage mais une situation explosive
avec l'arrivée au pouvoir de certains
partis dont on ne veut pas c'est aussi
ça aussi avoir un discours de fermeté
pour dire nous on est droit dans nos
bottes comme disait un ancien Premier
ministre est-ce qu'une absence de Tex
sur l'immigration ça fait le jeu des
extrêmes pour vous mais oui parce que on
le réclamait ce texte de il y a il y a
des des considérants qu'il faut avoir en
tête et et aujourd'hui une situation
d'accueil qui crée un un appel d'air
quoi qu'on en dise dans tous les
courants mais il y a il y a un appel
d'air qu'on veut qu'on veut résorber
parce que parce que sinon c'est la porte
ouverte à à une immigration incontrôlé
on va parler de des menaces qui pèsent
sur les enseignants on l' encore vu hier
à Arennes ou une collège G a menacé son
enseignante avec un couteau vous faites
partie de la mission de contrôle du
Sénat sur les menaces et agressions dont
sont victimes ses enseignants hier étit
auditionnés les représentants de la
police et de la gendarmerie on va en
parler tout de suite avec notre
journaliste Audrey
[Musique]
vetaz bonjour andudrey bonjour bonjour
Monsieur P bonjour et Audrey la mission
conjointe de contrôle des menaces contre
les enseignants auditionnit donc hier la
police et la gendarmerie pour savoir
comment elle traitait euh les menaces
contre le corps éducatif et comment les
plaintes des enseignants sont prises en
compte une audition qui a permis de
faire un état des lieux qu'est-ce qui
est fait qu'est-ce qui pourrait être
améliorer pour que des affaires comme
l'assassinat de Samuel pati ou
l'attentat d'arace ne se reproduisent
plus quelques chiffres pour commencer 55
% des auteurs de violence ou menace
contre les enseignants sont des adultes
c'est ça qui est assez étonnant souvent
extérieur à l'établissement et souvent
les menaces sont faites en ligne c'est
la raison pour laquelle le travail
d'enquête pour retrouver les auteurs
peut s'avérer compliqué côté prévention
cette audition nous a permis d'apprendre
aussi qu'il y a un référent éducation
dans chaque brigade de police et de
gendarmerie son rôle c'est de faire le
lien entre la communauté éducative et
les forces de l'ordre et d'inciter les
les professeurs pardon à porter plainte
et ça on va le voir c'est un point
d'amélioration il peut aussi y avoir une
protection spécifique en cas de menace
avec des patrouilles plus régulières
autour d'un établissement ou des forces
de police postées devant le domicile
d'un enseignant mais attention on ne
parle pas là de protection rapprochée ça
ça n'a concerné qu'une seule personne et
c'était en 2022 écoutez ce sont donc des
agents qui sont
H24 au contact d'une personne donc vous
imaginez que c'est un dispositif
exorbitant du droit commun qui est
évidemment très coûteux en en effectif
et qui ne peut pas être décliné en
n'importe quelle situation et qui a
vocation du coup à s'appliquer quand une
menace est avéré ça peut d'ailleurs par
exemple tenir à la personnalité de
quelqu'un qui a émis une menace sur sur
un enseignant ça peut conduire à la mise
en œuvre de cette mesure totalement
exceptionnelle et exorbitante de
protection rapprochée on comprend donc
que la protection rapprochée pour un
enseignant c'est vraiment l'exception et
puis dernière mesure quand un enseignant
est menacé il peut demander à être
enregistré dans un fichier pour que son
numéro soit reconnu et priorisé en cas
d'appel d'urgence et Audra parmi les
pistes d'amélioration police et
gendarmerie demandent un dépôt de
plainte systématique oui parce que
souvent les enseignants minimisent ce
qu'il leur arrive une menace de mort
après avoir confisqué un téléphone
portable on peut penser que ce sont les
mots en l'air d'un adolescent mais pour
André petillot le major général de la
gendarmerie nationale qui était
auditionné hier il ne faut rien laisser
passer de même que sur les violences
intrafiliales le message qu'on a fait
passer c'est la dépôt de plein
systématique je crois qu'il faut aller
sur le même logique en matière
d'atteinte aux enseignants parce que
finalement c'est on a bien vu que sur
les VF là au début toujours cette
logique de dire ouais mais relativiser
un petit peu finalement est-ce que ça
sert vraiment euh il y avait aussi
beaucoup de de victimes qui se
présentaient en disant bon je veux pas
déposer plainte mais je vous signale que
et puis on s'est aperçu à visage que
c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne
pour avoir un résultat efficace une
véritable répression et une exemplarité
il faut DESP de plinte systématique et
une fois qu'il y a dépôt de plainte le
système se met en route il y a des
investigations et il y a il y aura des
décisions ensuite judiciaire qui seront
prise monsieur le sénateur vous êtes
pour un dépôt de plainte systématique
oui on on voit que les choses avancent
et j'ai j'ai pas pu assister hier à
cette audition puisque j'ai accueillais
une une environnementaliste australienne
au même moment dans dans le cadre des
vous savez de l'accueil des des des
étrangers sur des influenceurs étrangers
on va dire ça comme ça et donc j'ai j'ai
réécouté ensuite l'audition j'ai j'ai
regardé ça attentivement
incontestablement les choses bougent du
côté du partenariat si je peux dire
entre l'éducation nationale la police et
la gendarmerie voilà il y a il y a des
choses positives dans le traitement de
laffirepathie j'ai écouté avec
attention l'audition de de de sa sœur
l'audition des des différents ministres
l'audition d'hier était intéressante
pour dire concrètement il y a la
plateforme phos vous savez qui qui est
un recensement systématique des des Sid
Allemands et les patrons de la police et
la gendarmerie insiste pour le fait
qu'il y ait un dépôt de plainte parce
que c'est ça qui déclenche des des des
opérations de de police de gendarmerie
on l'a vu avec bon l'assassinat de
Samuel Patti on a on a fait semaine par
semaine jour par jour
le les les les derniers événements avant
avant l'assassinat de Samuel paatti et
il n'a pas été suivi euh il y a eu un
problème de de de prise de conscience de
la gravité du du danger qui portait sur
lui je rappelle que quelques jours avant
de mourir on a on trouvait un marteau
dans dans son sac à dos parce qu'il se
savait menacer physiquement et il avait
conscience lui de de de du danger de
mort qui pesait sur lui à ce moment-là
on n pas de on n pas de suivi précis
donc oui le la la collaboration avec les
services de police et de garmerie
fonctionne mieux bien ce serait encore
un grand mot en tout cas il y a un
changement de paradigme sur le danger
qui pèse sur les sur les profès vous
l'avez dit 55 % des des agressions qui
sont les fait de de parents en fait he
d'adultes de parents de proches de de
grands frères de et ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut redonner à
l'école ce sanctuaire qu' n'aura jamais
du cesser d'être et on voit qu'il y a
aujourd'hui des intrusions on faisait
référence à la jeune de de 12 ans alors
elle était scolarisée mais enfin elle a
été exclue pour des raisons similaires
c'est-à-dire qu'elle portait un couteau
dans dans l'établissement dans lequel
elle a dont elle a été exclu l'année
dernière c'est extrêmement grave quand à
un moment donné j'ai pas souvenir
d'avoir croisé dans ma jeunesse des des
camarades qui portaient un couteau dans
leur sac à dos ça n'existe pas voilà
donc il y a donc c'est quoi une
radicalisation de la jeunesse plus de
violence aujourd'hui chez les jeunes oui
l'école d'une manière générale de toute
façon le Reflet de Société donc la
drogue y est plus plus plus abondante
les VI violence sont à un niveau
beaucoup plus élevé que les simples
bagarres de cours d'école qu'on a pu
connaître et puis l'islamisme a fait son
entrée d'une manière hyper hyper
puissante j'étais comme vous savez
rapporteur sur le texte sur les
principes des des respect des principes
de la République on a on a découvert un
monde que le grand public ignore
probablement donc et ça on l'a laissé
entrer petit à petit sur quoi sur
l'entrisme de l'islamisme à l'école
l'entrisme de
l'islamisme Jean-Michel blanquire dit
que c'est la fin du du du pas de vague
euh il était ministre de l'éducation
nationale au moment où j'étais
rapporteur euh alors je je pense qu'il a
pas eu totalement les coups des franches
pour aller jusqu'au bout de de de sa
volonté et de ses souhaits mais en tout
cas on on a abouti sur quoi sur des des
signature de Charte de la laïcité dans
des clubs de sport sur sur des
établissements scolaires je crois qu'il
faut il faut arrêter de de de de faire
des blagues à ce niveau-là quoi il faut
être beaucoup plus exigeant et quand une
élève porte un couteau dans un
établissement scolaire on doit prendre
des sanctions extrêmement sévères est-ce
que ça doit passer dans un internement
même si elle avait des des troubles
psychiatriques comme ça sembla
visblement là on n'est pas du tout sur
un sur un cadre radicalisation tel que
en l'état actuel de nos connaissances
donc mais justement enfin on sait bien
que c'est troubles à 12 ans des troubles
psychiatriques ça ça ça va déboucher sur
quoi quand elle sera majeure c'est
maintenant qu'il faut traiter ce
problème c'est pas c'est pas quand elle
aura vraiment commis quelque chose
d'irréparable justement on parle de
dépôt de plainte systématique dans
l'affaire de cette professeur de
français qui a reçu des menaces après
avoir montré un tableau de femme nu au
collège est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
doit y avoir un dépôt de plainte pour
cette affaire là pour éviter un
engrenage on a évoqué dans le cadre de
ces auditions la possibilité qu'il y ait
un dépôt de plainte pour l' par
l'établissement et là la professeur
n'est pas attaqué dans à titre personnel
elle est attaqué dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions de ses missions d'enseignantes
elle a tout à fait le droit de montrer
un tableau avec du nu ça existe dans
dans l'art donc l'établissement est est
habilité à à à faire un dépôt de plainte
au nom de bah du respect des des
missions des enseignants globalement
donc ça je pense que oui ça ça ça doit
être fait et là on voit bien qu'on a on
a un problème avec une avec certains
élèves qui considèrent que les principes
de leur religion sont au-dessus des
principes de la République c'est
exactement ce que l'on souhaitait
combattre dans le texte sur les
principes de la République je suis pas
convaincu qu'on soit arrivé au bout de
de de ce qu'on voulait faire et là on
voit on voit bien à tout moment on peut
être mis en question la pratique d'un
enseignant pour des motifs religieux on
était un peu dans le le même début de
situation que lors de l'affaire Samuel
passti justement avec aussi des des
dénonciations d'élèves Gabriel hatal
s'est rendu immédiatement sur place il a
annoncé des sanctions immédiates pour
les élèves qui ont été qui dit-il ont
reconnu les faits il dit on ne négocie
pas ni l'autorité de l'enseignant ni
l'autorité de nos règles ni nos valeurs
est-ce que ça change avec Gabriel àal
est-ce que vous approuvez ce discours de
fermeté moi j'ai totalement en phase
avec le discours de Gabriel Atal depuis
qu'il a été nommé ministre de
l'éducation nationale j'ai pu dire à
d'autres occasions à quel point j'ai
j'ai ressenti comme une provocation la
nomination de papendia précédemment
vraiment comme une provocation même en
tant
qu'enseignant Gabriel Atal prend des des
dispositions aujourd'hui qui vont
vraiment dans le bon sens maintenant il
faudra le mettre en application sur le
terrain sur la BAA il y a quand même des
années qu'on réclame une prise de
position du ministre de l'Éducation
parce que les enseignants le l'ensemble
de la communauté éducative a besoin de
cette de ces messages clairs du ministre
pour savoir où on en est exactement
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire il réclame ça
c'est pas c'est pas à eux de décider ce
qu'ils doivent accepter ou pas accepter
dans leur établissement il faut une
ligne clair ça manquait précédemment
donc Gabriel Atal prend des pour nous la
bonne direction maintenant il faudra
voir dans dans les faits comment ça se
traduit hier lors de l'audition il y a
eu un échange entre le sénateur
centriste Jean-Michel Arnaud et le
responsable de la gendarmerie pour
expliquer justement que qu'un dépôt de
plainte et peut-être qu'une enquête sur
un mineur ça peut parfois poser problème
pour la suite pour pour la réinsertion
de ce mineur si c'était éventuellement
des parents en l'air on est quand même
sur une ligne fine parce qu'on parle de
de mineur qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
mais bien sûr il y a il y a il y a une
présomption d'innocence a priori mais il
y a aussi parfois une une naïveté enfin
on est allé moi j'ai vécu vous savez des
des des choses où on reculait sur les
conseils de discipline parce que fallait
pas stigmatiser fallait pas mettre
l'élève en difficulté mais à un moment
donné quand on fait une bêtise il y a
des il y a des dispositions dans un
règlement inérieur d'établissement qui
sont prévus on applique ces dispositions
c'est pas un drame on tape sur les
doigts puis on dit voilà si tu ne
recommences pas mais non il fallait
toujours le pas de vague vous savez il y
a longtemps que ça existe donc quand il
y a matériellement quelque chose qui est
constaté sur un plus qu'un
dysfonctionnement un dérapage d'un élève
écoutez on prend des on prend des
mesures et le plutôt possible c'est le
mieux parce que il faut éviter qu'on
débouche sur sur des faits d'une d'une
d'une ampleur qu'on qu'on qu'on a connu
je vrais juste dire sur l'autorité de de
de de l'enseignant aussi ça c'est
important la parole du ministre pour
dire le professeur il est légitime dans
sa classe il a autorité dans sa classe
et quand on voit que les les grands
frères les parents sisent dans le rôle
du professeur je dis non moi le
professeur il gère sa classe il il doit
il a une autorité supérieure qui est son
chef d'établissement ok il doit rendre
des comptes à son chef d'établissement à
son inspecteur d'académie mais pas aux
parents les parents ils doivent ils
doivent pas sibisser dans le travail
pédagogique de l'enseignant mais c'est
ce qu'il fait non Gabriel notamment sur
la question du redoublement il redonne
la main le dernier mot au profess ça
encore une fois ça ça me va très bien
vous savez ça ça fait partie des
reculades successives qu'on a observé
dans dans l'éducation nationale et en
fait c'est la toute puissance vous savez
sur les redoublements au début on on
faisait des des conseils on donnait la
parole aux parents puis et au
professeurs puis après on a donné la
parole
uniquement parents et puis pour finir on
dit bon le redoublement ça sert à rien
bien sûr qu'ussi je peux vous dire dans
ma carrière d'enseignant j'ai vécu des
redoublements pas titre personnel pour
mes élèves extrêmement profitaable
extrêmement profitable donc c'est voilà
les pédagogistes qui nous disent ça sert
à rien il faut il faut avancer coûte que
coûte moi je je m'inscris en faux par
rapport à ça merci Audrey merci à tout à
l'heure oui on va parler de l'exécutif
qui semble avoir oublié que le groupe LR
à l'Assemblée a voté la motion de rejet
on en parle de ça dans le club des
territoires on termine avec l'actualité
chez vous Stéphan piennoir on va anger
on retrouve isrek Duran bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous reporter
politique au Courrier de l'Ouest Yve en
Une de votre journal matin un dossier
sur les enfants placés oui oui avec le
récit du parcours terrible d'un jeune
homme de 18 ans qui s'appelle michaell
qui est placé enfin qui a été placé
depuis ces 2 ans qui a été transféré de
famille en famille et qui aujourd'hui
majeur est livré à lui-même et dort dans
un parking souterrain en plein cœur du
cent-eville danger alors le les enfants
placés en méoire c'est un sujet très
c'est un sujet majeur il y a environ
2800 enfants qui sont placés c'est plus
15 % encore cette
année le département le Conseil
départemental a du mal à gérer en fait
ses chiffres monsieur le sénateur déjà
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire et dans
quelle mesure le Sénat peut se saisir de
cette
question j'ai j'ai lu le l'article du
Courrier de l'Ouest ce matin humainement
une situation absolument terrible on
voit que c'est un gamin depuis l'âge de
2 ans qui est bringballé de de famille
d'accueil en famille d'accueil de de
structure et et et et et c'est un échec
de ce point de vue-là mais je voudrais
rappeler que c'est ces enfants qui sont
placés en famille d'accueil qui qui
relèv de laazu sont d'abord extraits de
leur famille euh dans lesquels ils
subissent souvent des violences c'est ça
la la difficulté le le le paradoxe
ultime c'est que quand on est dans des
difficultés d'accueil quand on a on fait
le constat qu'on a pas la possibilité
d'accueillir des des enfants qui
relèvent de laazu on est parfois obligé
de laisser les enfants dans les familles
là même où ils vivent des situations
extrêmement violentes parfois c'est
c'est vraiment ça dont il faut avoir
conscience maintenant sur les chiffres
près de 3000 enfants qui qui relèvent de
la zoo le département est est submergé
il y a pas assez de famille d'accueil il
faut vous savez que laaz le département
doit fournir un un un un accueil du
urgence pendant quelques jours mais
l'accueil en hôtel on voit bien que
c'est pas du tout ce qu' ce qui convient
à à ces enfants là donc ce que ce que le
Sénat peut faire c'est simplement
conforter les moyens des départements
pour ce type de politique qui est une
politique
nationale on est sur une convention des
droits de l'enfant donc c'est un c'est
vraiment un principe national qui
s'impose au département qui doivent
appliquer une politique dont il sur
laquelle ils n'ont pas la main quoi et
aujourd'hui c'est c'est le c'est l'appel
au secours des conseillers
départementaux des présidents de
département qui disent donnez-nous les
moyens convenables d'accueillir ces
enfants pour que on n pas 16 ans après
le début d'un parcours absolument
catastrophique un un un jeune qui soit
dans cette situation là et dont on peut
craindre qu'il soit perdu pour pour
vraiment très longtemps on voit
l'agressivité qui qui ressort de votre
papier monsieur TRC
Duran vraiment de manière manière très
je précise Yve vous avez une autre
question B oui parce que vous le disiez
il y a des des enfants qui sont qui ne
peuvent pas être accueillis il y a
environ 200 enfants en menelloir qui
peuvent pas être retirés de leur famille
maltraitante parce qu'il y a pas de
solution pour pour
eux dans ces enfants placés il y a aussi
les mineurs non accompagnés donc ces
enfants qui arrivent de l'étranger qui
sont seuls c'est à peu près 150 en
ménéloire alors là je fais un petit lien
avec la loi immigration dont on parlait
tout à l'heure
mais com comment vous comment vous jugez
ça ce dilemme en fait il faut il
faudrait presque avoir à choisir c'est
c'est c'est un peu
terrible exactement on rejoint le thème
enfin le le sujet de la loi immigration
150 c'est c'est c'est 15000 à l'échelle
du territoire national c'est MNA avec
des des origine dont on peut contester
le le bien fondé si je peux dire
c'est-à-dire que on voit majoritairement
ces gamins viennent de viennent de
Guinée de Tunisie du Mali de de côte
d'ivoir on a on a un devoir d'accueil
d'asile pour des enfants qui sont sur
dans des pays en guerre les pays que
j'ai cité sont pas exactement dans cette
situation
là sur le Mali c'est c'est compliqué
mais voilà donc c'est ça aussi qu'on a
dans le dans le traitement de
l'immigration c'est
regarder sur quel critère on accueille
des jeunes il y a la présomption de
minorité aujourd'hui qui vaut pour un
pour un enfant qui se dit mineur
présomption de minorité nous on préfère
une présomption de majorité pour
quelqu'un qui refuse de se soumettre à
des testes
qui pourrait attester de de de sa
majorité parfois ça crève les yeux mais
quand on vous dit quand on vous oppose
la la présomption de minorité vous ne
pouvez vous ne pouvez rien faire et ça
aussi c'est un appel d'air on en parlait
tout à l'heure et je crois qu'il faut
être beaucoup plus ferme sur les
conditions d'accueil de de de ces
mineurs isolés parce qu'on ne pourra pas
tenir et on sait que c'est aussi un un
terau de délinquence plus de 30 % des
vols à Paris sont le fait de mineur
isolés c'est évidemment pas la
proportion de ce qu'il représente sur le
territoire ça va s'en dire donc on voit
bien qu'on a un lien entre ça l'accueil
de ces mineurs c'est soit-disant mineurs
et la délinquance sur no territoire
merci V regarde la une du Courrier de
l'Ouest vous en avez parlé à 18 ans la
descente aux enfers de Michel c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci beaucoup Yv
trek durant un mot pour terminer sur le
nucléaire puisque c'est un sujet sur
lequel vous travaillez beaucoup Stéphane
Piednoir hier il y a donc eu un accord à
Dubaï à la COP 28 qui appelle pour la
première fois abandonner les énergies
fossiles et Emmanuel Macron euh a poussé
pour le nucléaire lorsqu'il est allé à
Dubaï et la France a réussi à obtenir la
mention de l'énergie nucléaire comme un
moyen d'atteindre la décarbonation c'est
important je me réjouis qu'Emmanuel
Macron découvre les bienfaits de la
décarbonation via le nucléire c'était
pas le cas en 2017 avec jusqu'à l'arrêt
d'Astrid la fermeture de fessanaï et
puis subitement en 2022 la lumière est
venue et Emmanuel Macron a découvert
redécouvert le nucléaire c'est
intéressant comme comme démarche
évidemment au-udelà de la boutade je
plaide pour ça l'objectif numéro 1
toutes les copes sont sont sont des
accords historiques hein c'est c'est la
le terme qui est utilisé à chaque fois
en tout cas citer les énergies fossiles
comme la une fin en soi ça c'est même si
le terme progressif peut laisser augurer
d'un temps très très long mais en tout
cas faire de du nucléaire un obj un
objet plutôt un outil pour l'objectif
numéro 1 qui est juste la décarbonation
il faut qu'on se mette d'accord sur
notre on peut pas courir tous les
lièvres en même temps l'objectif mondial
c'est la décarbonation le nucléaire
c'est l'énergie décarboné par excellence
c'est moins que d'autres sources de de
renouvelable faut-il le rappeler on a
aussi de belles perspectives sur du
nucléaire durable il faut qu'on se
d'accord donc il faut arrêter de plaider
pour une baisse du nucléaire dans notre
mix énergétique mais ça déjà nous on l'a
arrêté au Sénat on a mis un dans le la
la loi la dernière loi on a on a mis fin
au au plafond des 50 % on aura d'autres
possibilités vous savez que la la
programmation pluréannuel de l'énergie
devra être discuté avec un an de retard
mais l'année prochaine on compte bien
aussi CR des choses y compris sur le
nucléaire voilà ça va dans le bon sens
mais mais que de temps perdu depuis 2017
merci Stéphane piennoir merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure